au royaume uni c'est un animal très
convoité la dinde est de loin le repas
de noël favori des britanniques
cette année la production que l'élevage
à l'assiette est particulièrement
compliqué
paul kelly qui élèvent des dizaines de
milliers de dinde explique que les
abattoirs et usines de transformation
tourne au ralenti faute d'employés un
certain moment il a même cru que la
production en vue de la saison des fêtes
était menacé une pénurie d'abord causé
par la pandémie puis aggravée par le
break site depuis que le royaume uni a
officiellement quitté l'union européenne
en janvier les travailleurs venant
d'europe de l'est très nombreux dans ce
secteur peuvent obtenir un visa
il n'y a pas que les abattoirs
britanniques qui sont confrontés à une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre le secteur du
transport fait lui aussi face à un
manque criant d'employés et l'absence de
ces camionneurs sur les routes du
royaume uni a des impacts bien visible
depuis quelques semaines ces scènes sont
fréquentes les stations d'essence sans
carburant en raison de manque de
livraison et d'une panique des
consommateurs des rayons d'épicerie ont
aussi parfois été privés de produits
frais
le gouvernement britannique a déployé
l'armée pour approvisionner les stations
service est annoncé l'octroi de quelques
milliers de visas pour les camionneurs
mais les besoins sont bien plus grands
fauves de travailleurs étrangers et en
raison des retards dans les formations
cas entraîner la pandémie le royaume uni
aurait besoin de 100 mille de ces
conducteurs
pour cet expert ces pénuries qui
touchent différents secteurs de
l'économie était prévisible
des changements que l'on constate déjà à
brommat qui est un véritable îlot
européen au coeur de londres fromage
français saucisson italien l'endroit est
idéal pour trouver les aliments du
continent de ce côté ci de la manche
mais importer ce genre de produit n'est
plus aussi simple qu'auparavant
pour cette commerçante qui vend du miel
et des fleurs venues d'italie cela
signifie trois fois plus de formulaires
et des coûts supplémentaires désormais
trop peu profitable les fleurs ne sont
plus sur les étalages
ne pouvions plus justifier ses
importations dit elle une situation déjà
complexe alors que les nouvelles règles
douanières entre le royaume uni l'union
européenne ne sont que partiellement
entrée en vigueur elles seront
entièrement appliquée à partir de
janvier
pour l'instant ce commerçant qui importe
aussi des produits italiens assurent
avoir pu tirer son épingle du jeu malgré
les récents changements difficile de
prévoir si à l'avenir il faudra encore
s'adapter
paul kelly lui anticipe des changements
à long terme dans son industrie pour
l'instant la saison des fêtes devrait
être sauvé le gouvernement va octroyer
des visas aux travailleurs européens ces
prochaines semaines die presse
mais vu la pénurie anticipée l'industrie
britannique avait déjà prévu de vendre
500 1000 de moins que l'année dernière
moins d'un an après la sortie officielle
de l'union européenne ce sont donc des
produits néerlandais français qui
pourrait s'inviter sur la table de
certains anglais à noël
pour paul kelly cette situation est
d'une grande ironie il cira fait le
bouvier auclair radio-canada à danbury
wang